des milandes au coeur du périgord noir
pour un inattendu et exceptionnel le 30
novembre prochain joséphine baker
deviendra la première femme noire honoré
au panthéon un événement dont on peut
mesurer l'importance en connaître la vie
de l'artiste et notamment la vie de
l'artiste dans ce château du xvème
siècle là monsieur bonsoir je voudrais
regarder la france au fond des yeux
j'aimerais beaucoup de femmes apprennent
à tricoter d'accord là-dessus à votre
place je la ramène un peu moins mais si
vous ne réussissez pas c'est qu'il vous
manque qu'une seule chose que tout
petits détails
quand je me suis mis les pieds sur le
sol français de la première fois 5 et
que mon extraordinaire agissante et la
liberté libre et dans ce mode est bien
jeter aux russes de temps franche je
suis dit enfin libre enfin libre
formidable déclaration d'amour de
joséphine baker pour la france ce coup
de foudre dont parle artistes
afro-américains apôtre de la liberté
c'était en 1925 bonjour angélique de
labarre vous êtes la propriétaire de ce
château vous entretenez l'esprit et
l'histoire de joséphine baker parce que
pour bien comprendre l'artiste il faut
connaître sa passion pour la france bien
sûr mais aussi pour ce château qui
occupe une place particulière dans sa
vie oui on sait que joséphine est folle
de paris de la france et elle découvre
en fait le château des milandes en 1937
elle a un coup de coeur extraordinaire
pas simplement pour le château la
bâtisse mais pour son environnement
elle trouve que le périgord est une
terre extraordinaire une terre d'accueil
et de patrimoine la belle je vous
propose de nous accompagner dans cette
inattendue pour une petite visite l'idée
du château des seigneurs bien sûr
[Musique]
d'eux un bon
alors là on a toutes les chambres
d'enfants notamment celles ci une petite
chambre toute mignonne pour les bébés
voyez et on va rentrer dans la salle de
la résistance on à la salle de la
résistance pour pour découvrir un aspect
méconnu de la vie de joséphine baker
avec ludivine d'opeth journaliste à la
rédaction dina bonjour ludivine j'aurais
évoqué une aide mémorables de sa vie ces
années de résistance pendant la seconde
guerre mondiale c'est d'ailleurs l'une
des raisons de sa panthéonisation oui en
1940 joséphine à cacher ici dans ce
château situé en zone libre ceux qui
fuyaient la france ceux qui fuyaient la
france occupée par les allemands il ya
aussi cacher des armes pourquoi
angélique de labarre joséphine baker
star du music-hall seidel lancer dans
cette aventure de résistance parce
qu'elle se sent profondément française
puisque les français l'acceptent et
l'accueil en 1925 lors de la revue [ __ ]
elle descend du train et les français
lui sourit même les blancs et elle
trouve ça extraordinaire sur tous les
blancs d'ailleurs donc elle a envie de
se donner à ce pays qui est sa nouvelle
patrie et elle va le dire fait de moi ce
que vous voulez donc elle s'est révélée
très efficace
ludivine joséphine baker at elle évoqué
cette période de sa vie à la télévision
oui elle en a parlé à la télévision mais
aussi plus longuement à la radio et
c'est d'ailleurs ces moments que j'ai
choisi de vous partager en 1968 par
exemple elle participait à l'émission à
coeur ouvert sur france inter et
lorsqu'elle parlait de son action dans
la résistance elle disait finalement
c'est avait rien d'héroïque je laisse
regarder en gélules merci beaucoup j'ai
fait tant bien que mal j'ai fait mon
deux fois alors là vous voyez que je
suis encore un petit peu parce qu'il
faut parler de moi et je trouve qu'il
faut pas parler de moi quand je suis pas
un personnage qu'elle dans la résistance
quand il ya des milliers de centaines de
milliers d'autres qui ont fait beaucoup
beaucoup plus que moi moi j'étais
le tout petit grain de sable qui a voulu
se joindre à d'autres grandes sabre pour
faire une montagne de vérité et tout ça
c'était construit sur un idéal auquel tu
défendes encore aujourd'hui et que je
défendrai jusque la fin car c'est ça la
vérité on a entendu on découvre là une
joséphine baker patriotes elle le dit
c'était son devoir de servir son pays
est ce qu'elle se sentait redevable
envers la france joséphine baker oui il
sentait complètement redevables puisque
arrivant des états unis où il ya
énormément de discrimination elle elle
comprend que la france est un pays de
liberté d'amour et elle veut se donner à
ce pays c'est quand même fou c'est une
des rares à s'engager dès 1939 il y en a
beaucoup qui au début était et
pétainiste donc elle veut s'engager elle
ne sait pas qui est le général de gaulle
et pourtant elle y va et chaque
réengagement a plus que pour la france
joséphine baker va même accepté de jouer
les espionnes oui dès le début de la
guerre elle propose son aide aux
services secrets de la france libre elle
devient agent du contre-espionnage
français joséphine va glaner des
informations dans toute l'europe elle va
aussi passer des documents sensibles à
d'autres relais de la résistance et
quand des journalistes l'interrogeaient
sur ses motivations quelques années plus
tard c'était toujours les mêmes réponses
je montre pourquoi avez vous accepté
d'entrer dans les services secrets
pour défendre la france
mondial qui la vôtre j'espère
la dignité humaine
et pour l'humanité entière
c'est magnifique c'est magnifique et
elle veut absolument lutter jusqu'à la
libération de la france en raison
justement pour défendre la france pour
lutter contre pour son idéal jusqu'où
joséphine baker est elle allée pour
recueillir ces informations à secrète
alors d'abord quand elle est aux
milandes elle reste une année en 1940
mais elle va quand même caché des armes
elle va cacher des documents ne sait pas
toujours ce qu'il ya dans les documents
mais on lui dit on vous amène des
documents voulait cacher et ensuite
voulait renvoyer peut-être à londres au
général de gaulle est caché dans ses
alors elle et qu'elle est caché dans les
soutiens-gorge suivant et qu'ils
allaient fouiller joséphine baker
c'était pas possible d'ailleurs elle
signé plus tôt des autographes
lorsqu'elle était au niveau des
frontières entre les zones occupées des
zones libres sur ses partitions aussi l
aile dissimulé des informations voilà l
écrivait l encre sympathique
elle était quand même bien éduqué jeudi
la journée c'est le lieu idéal dans les
services secrets joséphine travaillait
avec le commandant jacques a ptet en
1963 il parlait de cette collaboration à
la télévision et il n'était pas peu fier
de sa coéquipière je vous laisse
découvrir j'ai retenu joséphine baker
après la loi fait pressentir en raison
d'un amour inouïe de la france son
désintéressement total
son intelligence est un courage à toute
épreuve je puis dire que je ne me suis
pas trompé
c'est merveilleux je n'avais jamais vu
cette archive il évoque plusieurs
qualités en jete fine des coeurs mais
l'une des principales c'était quand même
sa notoriété elle lui permettait
d'accéder aux hautes sphères politiques
et puis surtout elle l'a protégé des
soupçons vous l'avez évoqué tout à
l'heure c'est surtout pour ça pour sa
notoriété finalement qu'elle a été
choisie non joséphine oui au début ils
voient bien c'est la grande star des
années 30 donc il sait qu'elle pourra
passer les frontières qu'elle peut
transmettre des messages qu'on va pas
aller la fouille et elle est quand même
allé danser et chanter à vienne à munich
à berlin lc c'est ce qui se passe en
europe elle est intelligente lui n'avait
pas cru au départ qu'elle serait capable
de faire tout ça il pensait à une fille
frivole la ceinture de bananes le music
hall en réalité elle se révèle très
efficace et elle va lutter jusqu'à la
fin et moi j'ai une admiration énorme
pour joséphine autre date importante en
1941 le combat de joséphine pour la
france libre continue mais au maroc oui
parce qu'en france elles commencent à
être soupçonné un par les allemands elle
fut donc la france pour le maroc en
afrique du nord elle continue ses
activités de contre-espionnage et entame
surtout une longue tournée une série de
concerts au profit de la france libre
mais aussi au profit du général de
gaulle une personne qu'elle adorait
écouter je voulais vous faire écouter
d'ailleurs comment elle parlait de lui
c'est en 1944 à la radio formidable nous
avions
le
général de gaulle oui je tombe vous
voulez me parler du général de gaulle il
est monde entier de l'homme de tous les
couleurs sont venus délit encourt
aveuglement vers lui c'est plus pour que
soit il fait ce qu'il veut il veut bien
pour relève et l'apport à un fui en
effet des trophées
on entend la fascination à de joséphine
baker pour cet homme qu'est ce qu'il
représentait pour elle pour elle il n'y
avait que cet homme qui pouvait
permettre la libération du pays donc
pour elle il est aussi important de
fédérer tout le monde c'est à dire
qu'elle va être ami avec des résistants
communistes
elle va voir des gens de tous bords bien
sûr et toute sa vie d'ailleurs c'est ce
qu'elle fera et c'est ce qui est
formidable chez elle donc le général de
gaulle elle le voit en 1943 elle reçu la
croix de lorraine en or et d'ailleurs
la honoré non bien sûr il l'honore et à
ce moment là elle et elle est
complètement subjugué par cet homme oui
en 1943 vous l'avais dit à angélique de
labarre ils se sont rencontrés donc le
général de gaulle et joséphine baker à
alger en 1943 il lui offre une petite
croix de lorraine symbole de la france
libre en 1944 un an plus tard elle est
promue sous lieutenant de l'armée de
l'air d'autres décorations viendront
s'ajouter à son uniforme la croix de
guerre la médaille de la résistance et
plus tard en 1961 la légion d'honneur il
me semble que cette dernière décoration
a fait débat oui certains militaires ont
remis en question plus ou moins les
engagements les les gestes de joséphine
baker enfin tout ce qu'elle a fait
pendant la guerre on sait qui est
certains étaient un peu raciste et
comprenait pas pourquoi une telle femme
qui n'est pas française pouvait être
décoré en réalité ils n'ont pas compris
quel avant même
l'année 44 et bien elle s'est engagée
depuis 1939 et de manière très
insidieuse elle est l honorable
correspondante du capitanat pts et et
personne ne l'a su il était fait rager
fine baker de ceux de cet uniforme de
ses décorations d'ailleurs elle portait
cet uniforme et ses décorations en 1963
aux côtés de martin luther king à
washington pour la marche de washington
pour l'emploi et la liberté elle était
vraiment fier examen unique pour elle
elle était quasiment la seule femme à
parler et c'était je crois très émouvant
elle avait d'ailleurs d un peu des
trémolos dans la voix elle sentait que
son combat contre le racisme
allez peut-être aboutir dans son pays
d'origine
voilà joséphine baker résistante
joséphine baker militants de la lutte
contre le racisme
merci beaucoup ludivine pour ce dossier
et nous on va poursuivre notre visite et
continuer à découvrir une autre facette
de joséphine baker il fallait un petit
peu plus connus du grand public je vous
emmène hésite
ouah
non
alors ludivine souligné le rôle de son
métier pour mener ces différents combats
que ce soit dans la résistance ou contre
le racisme joséphine baker savez
utiliser son image pour faire passer des
messages comme cette ceinture de bananes
c'est un des objets les plus souvent
associés à l'artiste quelle est
l'histoire de cette ceinture angélique
alors cette ceinture d'abord elle a été
portée en 1927 28 aux folies bergères
donc pour une revue qui s'appelait la
folie du jour joséphine grâce à cette
ceinture c'est vrai avoir quasiment le
premier rôle elle ne mesure peut-être
pas le message qu'elle va porter d'abord
bon on sait on est en pleine année folle
moi je dis que c'est le costume le plus
connu du music-hall français et elle
apporte pourquoi c'est une critique plus
ou moins du colonialisme avec cette
fameuse revue la folie du jour on se
moque du colonialisme on se moque des
blancs mais c'est pour un public
français et blanc il y aura quand même
des détracteurs les gens un petit peu
pas intégriste mais certains diront
qu'on est plus vite redescendu à l'ère
du singe avec cette ceinture de bananes
évidemment elle la porte elle est
quasiment nue sur scène alors on va
rester sur scène avec joséphine baker
puisque notre traditionnel zapping est
consacrée à l'artiste joséphine baker
ils m'apprennent sa petite bourgeoise a
tout piqué sa tante qui s'attend kinoise
et deux à bout
mon père y
arrive toujours
cris est gravé à savoir email
mi
mai
une immense force a annoncé paris
horie
tout autre
enjeu prends
je pense à ceux qui souffrent qui loin
de leur foyer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le
sait pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sourit toujours souri
[Musique]
témoignage
nous sommes et bananes
ouais
moi j'avais dévoile un autre fois c'est
que je ne
vois là on arrive dans la cuisine de ce
château des milandes nous retrouvons
géraldine corner lavaud journaliste à la
rédaction dinars dont le jour géraldine
alors c'est vrai que cette pièce a
souvent été filmé par la télévision
française pour des bons et parfois des
mauvais moments on va en reparler alors
l'action est l'histoire de joséphine
baker sont absolument indissociable de
ce château on va s'intéresser maintenant
à la vie de famille de l'artiste ou
plutôt la vie de château oui sa vie de
château dès 1949 en plus de sa vie de
château joséphine baker achète pas mal
de terrain autour pour construire un
village de la fraternité qu'est ce que
c'était ça ce village la fraternité
angélique alors eh bien écoutez elle a
envie d'adopter des enfants elle ne peut
pas en avoir a peut pas avoir d'enfant
naturel et son envie d'abord quand elles
arrivent ici elle sent que tout le monde
veut venir la voir donc elle crée un
parc d'attractions et ce village vient
de son envie d'adoption et de montrer au
monde entier que des enfants de
nationalités et de religions différentes
peuvent vivre ensemble dans la joie et
dans la paix donc c'est ce qu'elle
appellera son village capitale de la
fraternité universelle alors joséphine
baker va aller plus loin que celui l'âge
de la fraternité 1 puisqu'elle va
adopter douze enfants douze enfants
venant de pays différents la faute à
tous les citer mais alors il ya la
france mais il ya le maroc il ya là
correia le japon il ya le venezuela
c'était vraiment l appeler ça une tribu
arc en ciel c'est joli je pense qu'il
fallait noter
elles définissent est ce vraiment c'est
prévu comme vous l'avez dit à un message
un symbole pour se dire que on a des
couleurs différentes de pau on vient de
pays différents on a des cultures et des
religions différentes d'ailleurs et
chaque enfant avait des cours de culture
et de religion pour autant on peut
grandir dans la paix dans l'amour sans
haine ni racisme est donc ce message là
elle n'a cessé de le répéter à la
télévision comme en 1961 jour de noël et
elle explique son projet de familles
arc-en-ciel je vous montre formidable
le sapin était couvert de boules de
toutes les couleurs les onze enfants qui
s'accrochent aux branches étaient aussi
de toutes les couleurs il y en avait
deux noirs deux jaunes 4 blanc un rouge
un café au lait et un extrêmement rose
tous ces enfants portait le même nom ils
parlaient tous avec le nice 1 celui du
pérou l'est
j'ai eu cette idée quand ce que j'ai vu
tellement de
l'incompréhension entre les êtres
humains des soi-disant adultes et je
déçu qu'avec nos petits-enfants innocent
il pouvait bien exemple absolu de la
fraternité mondiale ce n'est qu'en
france qu'on pourrait donner une telle
exemple de toutes ses petits-enfants au
nom de quel droit demande et vivent ici
vraiment un frein en frais s'émeut
magnifique ces combats qui est le combat
de sa vie et elle veut en fait combattre
bon le racisme bien sûr mais se battre
pour la différence en permanence et il
ya aussi des messages politiques puisque
quand elle adopte akio et jeannot il y
en a un tous les deux par dons sont
japonais mais elle va faire faire un
passeport coréen à aquio pour que quand
elle entre à l'aéroport à paris elle
montre ses deux enfants un coréen un
japonais est elle-même franco-américaine
c'est un message fort après la deuxième
guerre mondiale est quasiment pendant la
guerre froide et du coup comment c'était
perçu dans le voisinage dans le périgord
dans les années 60 cette femme
américaine noire avec douze enfants de
toutes les couleurs de toutes les pays
alors le périgord même si on a
l'impression d'être un pays assez fermé
on aime les gens et vous voir des
enfants après la guerre justement après
la seconde guerre mondiale voire des
enfants d'un peu partout je pense que
c'était pour eux très important alors
bien sûr il n'avait jamais vu de gens de
couleur odb et pourtant on habite le
périgord noir voyez et ça a été
compliqué un petit peu au départ mais le
périgourdin est intelligent et comprend
vite que pour en plus pour ce
département joséphine a amené énormément
économiquement et voilà elle aimait les
gens donc elle l'a montré et puis en
plus elle était vraiment à l'habiter ici
il y avait le ramassage scolaire
invité de les petits copains d'école
c'est qu'en fait c'était sa résidence
principale en 47 elle achète le château
49 elle inaugure son parc d'attraction
elle crée le ramassage scolaire comme
vous dites et et en même temps elle
amène l'eau l'électricité courante n'y
avait rien de chauffage central c'est
elle pourquoi joséphine baker sur ses
douze enfants adoptés dix garçons et
deux filles oui ça m'a toujours amusé et
en réalité jo bouillon le mari de
joséphine ne voulait adopter que des
garçons il avait dit je veux cinq ou six
garçons parce que les filles c'est
compliqué et les allumer joséphine est
allé bien plus loin et elle adopte
effectivement au moins deux filles qui
sauve l'honneur je tairai alors
malheureusement
1964 le conte de fée se gâtent joséphine
est criblé de dettes et le château est
menacé d'être vendus et encore une fois
c'est médiatisé les caméras de la
télévision française sont là je vous
laisse écouter c'est un sujet de 1964
écoutez le ton employé le journaliste
les milandes non plus déjà depuis huit
jours ni l'eau ni l'électricité le
téléphone de l'hôtel est coupée et une
vente mobilière est annoncée pour le 9
juin est ce le commencement de la fin de
ce qui est pourtant un rêve presque
entièrement réalisé quand tu aimes mes
amis concert qui croit que je vais
raison de créer village par et de la
fatalité
et vous accepterez cette fois je crois
que vous avez toujours refusé jusqu'à
présent l'aide de vos amis s cube
l'accepteriez mais je suis bien obligé
aussi musique un petit peu dramatique
assez de musique dramatique et surtout
il ya le mot un rêve presque réalisé
c'est un crève coeur à ce moment là pour
joséphine baker en 64 oui et elle
n'imaginait aucun moment qu'elle va
perdre le château des milandes pour elle
c'est un peu son 13e enfants c'est un
rêve qu'elle a constituée autour de
toute sa famille même sa maman est venu
l'aider son frère sa soeur elle
n'imagine pas un instant qu'elle puisse
perdre ce château des milandes oui alors
joséphine baker est une femme courageuse
pour sauver son château elle décide de
remonter sur scène nous sommes en 1964
elle a même une chanson sur les milandes
pendant cette tournée qu'elle appelle
mon village s'organise aussi une
campagne de communication pour sauver le
château des millions mais ça va au delà
parce que une star de l'époque vraiment
très connu à l'époque brigitte bardot
qui ne connaissait pas personnellement
en plus joséphine baker appelle la
télévision française en disant je veux
passer un message je veux aider
joséphine baker écoutez je vais vous
parler de ce qui arrive en ce moment à
joséphine bancaire je trouve
personnellement que c'est bouleversant
et que nous devons tous faire quelque
chose pour elle j'estime de cette femme
avec beaucoup de courage dans sa vie et
a toujours été très généreuse et en ce
moment nous ne pouvons pas la laisser
dans cette situation
alors je sais qu'en général les appels
lancés à la télévision n'ont jamais été
sans réponse c'est pourquoi je vous
demande à tous aujourd'hui de faire le
maximum de vos possibilités pour venir
en aide à joséphine baker et ça a marché
il ya eu des dons il y a des dons qui
affluent d'un peu partout de la france
sauf que ça ne suffit pas pour renflouer
les dettes quoique en fait joséphine
aurait pu vendre quelques terres
puisqu'elle avait 300 hectares de terres
mais elle refuse systématiquement toutes
les aides et
et surtout ne veut pas vendre parce
qu'elles pensent que son rêve serait
brisée mais les dons ne suffisent pas
1968 le château est vendu aux enchères
pour un prix bien inférieur à sa valeur
en 1969 quelques jours avant l'expulsion
officiel les enfants sont partis
joséphine baker elle est toujours là et
elle y croit elle est toujours là dans
cette cuisine là où quelques années
avant on entendait le rire des enfants
joséphine baker a apporté le plat de
spaghettis voilà là c'est plus du tout
la même ambiance elle est barricadée
dans cette cuisine elle a fait descendre
un lit il ya vraiment une voilà une
planche de bois qui voulait en fait elle
apprend que le nouveau propriétaire a
investi les lieux donc les hommes de
main sont là et elle ne veut pas lâcher
son château donc elle revient de paris
elle prend un train se barricadent elle
fermée trois portes ici la télé est venu
l'interviewer dans cette cuisine varika
des arènes et c'est assez hallucinant je
crois que vous voulez me demander ce que
je vais faire oui parce que j'ai planté
oui eh bien
je vais rester là
et je vais essayer de voir tout le
château de nouveau je suis décidé de me
laisser mourir à la fin
pour montrer à quel point qu'il est
nécessaire d'arrêter tous et justice et
contacte quand en france comme ailleurs
et au final quelques jours avant
quelques heures après cette vidéo vous
le disait elle se fait mettre dehors
comme une maintenance et ça comme une
malpropre les hommes demain la jette
dehors par cette porte et personne ne
l'a aidé angeli que devient joséphine
baker après sa vie de 1969 après avoir
quitté le château des milandes alors
c'est une vie difficile parce que
d'abord elle s'est battue pour le
général de gaulle qui a perdu et qui est
parti elle a perdu son château des
milandes et heureusement 69 d'abord elle
avait bien mis les enfants à l'abri à
paris dans des temps des grands collèges
mais une femme extraordinaire qui l'a
toujours suivi et toujours aidés va
encore les d une nouvelle fois et se
porter caution pour que joséphine achète
une ville à monaco c'est la princesse
grace de monaco est ce que la france
n'avait pas un rôle à jouer plus
important pour aider joséphine baker 6,6
d'ailleurs elle dira en partant des
milandes qu'elle ne veut absolument plus
chanter en france mais je pense que pour
elle c'était un déchirement alors elle
organise des concerts à l'étranger dans
les pays d'origine de ses enfants elle
part chanter et notamment en finlande
elle va beaucoup dans les pays nordiques
il faut accepter aussi encore de faire
chanter joséphine baker elle est moins
connue et il y à une nouvelle génération
qui passe devant elle aussi les johnny
hallyday michel sardou et pourtant elle
a beaucoup de succès et enfin on va lui
proposer quand même de se produire en
france oui merci beaucoup angélique pour
cette visite historique du château et de
la vie de joséphine baker merci à vous
géraldine pour pour ce dossier je vous
rappelle un 30 novembre la
panthéonisation de joséphine baker on se
quitte avec notre traditionnel pépites
et c'est vous angélique de labarre qui
l'avait choisie c'est le mariage de
joséphine baker et jo bouillon en 1947
pourquoi ce choix parce que j'avais
envie que vous terminiez par quelque
chose de très gai ce que joséphine baker
est une femme extrêmement gay et joyeuse
et ce mariage pour tout le périgord ça a
été un moment merveilleux et notamment
aussi pour mes voisins regardez comme si
vous y étiez sous d'autres cieux le
château des milandes que l'on dirait
sortis d'un conte de fées abrite les
épousailles de joséphine baker et de jo
bouillon noces campagnarde ou l'offrande
rituel du va et de la soupe à l'oignon
marié m'inquiète une tradition aussi
vieille que le donjon du château bon
vieux donjon aussi solennelle qui
n'avait jamais assisté 1
ja je devenais
[Musique]
voilà un peu de vin et la soupe à
l'oignon pour le chabrot des mariés vous
pouvez bien sûr venir ici au milan d'un
visiter cet incroyable château on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine sur france
info canal 27 et en attendant sur les
réseaux sociaux que ce soit ceux de
l'ina ou ceux de france info l'émission
préparée avec les documentalistes
florence lui c'est clair brûlé et mini
galtier merci à elle et merci à vous
d'être là chaque semaine
[Musique]